l'europe et la nécessité d'un consensus
face à la crise des réfugiés nous
recevons ce soir harlem désir
secrétaires d'état aux affaires
européennes bonsoir bonsoir et merci
d'être avec nous donc pour ce
rendez-vous de public sénat avec l'
agence france-presse
et dailymotion trois parties et 3
questions pour vous à raismes désir ce
soir sur les réfugiés l'union européenne
peut-elle imploser vous nous direz dans
un instant deuxième question tout à
l'heure que vous posera perrine tarneaud
peut-on faire confiance à alexis tsipras
ce pour qu'il mette en oeuvre évidemment
les réformes promises l'été dernier
troisième et dernière question est cette
fois vous répondrez à samir tounsi de
l'agencé france presse emmanuel macron
at il encore sa place au gouvernement
parmi vos collègues vous répondrai tout
à l'heure harlem désir vous
accompagnerez ce mercredi françois
hollande au sommet des chefs d'état et
de gouvernement à bruxelles sur la
question des réfugiés
face à l'afflux de réfugiés et de
migrants avec la division que l'on voit
entre l'est et l'ouest du continent
est ce que l'europe peut imposer même si
la question peut être posée différemment
avec l'accord majoritaire mais pas
unanime qui a été obtenu par les
ministres de l'intérieur sur la
répartition c'est une épreuve de vérité
et c'est pour cela que le conseil
européen auquel le président de la
république se rend demain est
extrêmement important aujourd'hui il
vient d'y avoir un premier accord lors
de ce conseil justice et affaires
intérieures ou le ministre de
l'intérieur bernard cazeneuve nous
représentait sur la répartition des 120
mille réfugiés en plus des 40 milles sur
lesquels il y avait déjà eu une décision
de prise au mois de juillet entre les 28
pays de l'union européenne c'était
extrêmement important un accord est
majoritaire je le disais un accord à
d'unanimité toujours il ya la fracture
qui demeure il aurait été préférable que
tout se mette d'accord par consensus
parce que c'est toute l'europe qui est
appelé à la solidarité il a fallu passer
à un vote mais l'europe c'est cela aussi
c'est la capacité à prendre des
décisions et à ne pas être bloqués parce
que quelques pays qui représentaient une
minorité n'aurait pas voulu adopter
cette écriture dont il ya une très large
majorité
si une majorité qualifiée et à partir de
maintenant on va donc
pouvoir mettre en oeuvre cet accord
cette répartition solidaire des réfugiés
qu'ils ont en besoin de protection
internationale du ciel ressort la
situation c'est la suivante d'après
l'organisation internationale des
migrations depuis le début de l'année il
ya 430 mille migrants qui ont tenté de
franchir et qui ont franchi la
méditerranée 2750 qui sont morts ou qui
ont disparu ce sont des chiffres
oui sans précédent c'est le plus grand
mouvement de population en europe depuis
la fin de la seconde guerre mondiale
pour l'europe il y à un test de à la
fois d'humanité de crédibilité et
d'efficacité d'humanité parce que
l'asile
c'est un des principes fondamentaux pour
nos pays nous sommes engagés à la fois
par des conventions internationales et
par nos nos propres règles à protéger
ceux qui sont persécutés
ceux qui par exemple aujourd'hui fui des
guerres ou des dictatures et et qui pour
cette raison se tourner vers l'europe
mais il ya aussi la nécessité de faire
face d'une façon collective solidaire on
ne peut pas y avoir 28 réponse nationale
c'est pourquoi il était important qu'il
y ait cet accord aujourd'hui à bruxelles
dans ce conseil des ministres que vous
dites de la hongrie de la roumanie de la
slovaquie qui ont voté contre eux disent
non nous on ne marche pas dans cet
ensemble on va leur appliquer quoi là la
solidarité du bavarois
moi je veux noter que d'autres pays qui
dans un premier temps avait dit qu'il ne
voulait pas participer à cette décision
on finit par y adhérer c'est le cas
notamment d'autres pays d'europe
centrale et orientale
donc ça veut dire qu'on peut dépasser
cette coupure qui avait semblé
s'exprimer par exemple la pologne malgré
le fait qu'il y avait une campagne
populiste nationaliste très très dur lp
mais l'ampleur des manifestations de
l'aigle noir plus en plus a besoin du
moins il ya un certain nombre d'autres
pays qui ont voulu jusqu'au bout refusé
ce principe certain qu'ils ont même été
jusqu'à ériger un rideau de fer comme la
hongrie quand on pense que la hongrie
s'est battu pour abattre un rideau de
fer il ya 25 ans s'est battu pour que le
mur qui séparait l'est et l'ouest ne ne
puisse pas empêcher ses citoyens de
rejoindre l'europe de la liberté il ya
même eu des épisodes de l'histoire je
pense à la répression contre le
mouvement démocratique à budapest en
1956 où des centaines de milliers de
hongrois ont été cherché refuge à
l'ouest de même que d'eau
sorti alors de la hongrie qui place dans
l'union dont vous avez rappelé les
grandes valeurs et la première
l'humanité notamment
est-ce que la hongrie encore sa place
dans l'union je l'espère mais je me sens
mais bien de bien entendu et d'ailleurs
je pense qu'elle respectera la décision
qui vient d'être adoptée à la majorité
quel banquier vous le promets
villeurbanne n'est pas du tout sur cette
ligne là il a envie qu'il vient de faire
passer une loi au parlement à budapest
où l'avait vue qui permet aux forces de
l'ordre de tirer avec débat est-ce que
c'est leur caoutchouc contre les
réfugiés qui essaient de franchir
est ce que l'on peut considérer que cela
c'est l'europe non ce n'est pas l'europe
il sogno richard héros de fer avec des
pays voisins
certains qui sont des pays membres de
l'union européenne comme la roumanie
puisque la hongrie a annoncé qu'elle
mettrait aussi en prière accès ou la
haute qui sont des pays qui ont vocation
à nous rejoindre comme la serbie donc
saluer une atterrissage à peu près ce
n'est pas l'europe l'europe ce n'est pas
ça il n'y a pas une europe où il y
aurait la solidarité à l'intérieur et
qu'est ce que l'une des valeurs à la
vidéo qu'est ce que l'europe ce sont des
valeurs que nous partageons leur dalle
va sur un parlement
j'ai alors il est au des sanctions par
exemple mais l'europe ce ne sont pas
simplement des fonds structurels ou un
marché intérieur où une zone de libre
échange
l'europe c'est d'abord un projet
politique qui est fondée sur des valeurs
démocratiques que nous avons en partage
et c'est aussi sa une un projet
apparemment oui mais il a réclamé des
sanctions je pense qu il faut qu il faut
d'abord qu'il y ait ce débat l'europe
c'est d'abord le principe de solidarité
tous ont eu besoin à un moment ou un
autre de la solidarité
et quand ils en ont eu besoin ils ont
souhaité que les autres pays soit à
leurs côtés soit pour des raisons dans
l'écurie par je ne développe aujourd'hui
et victor or aujourd'hui il ya des pays
qui sont des pays de en première ligne
d'une certaine façon où arrivent les
réfugiés c'est la grèce c'est l'italie
ça a été aussi la hongrie on peut on
peut comprendre que la hongrie et
demander la solidarité
mais là elle a refusé le principe de la
solidarité et du fait d'accueillir en
commun celles et ceux qui ont le droit
de réserve
il faut aussi en même temps dont il ya
un contrôle de nos frontières et à
carrière commune en france sinon c'est
schengen qui sera remis aux agriculteurs
sorbonne il faut essayer de convaincre
de dialoguer encore avec lui mais on a
entendu parler oui ce sur quoi je
voudrais insister c'est que la france
depuis le début de cette crise a une
position constante cohérente qui est de
demander qu'il y ait une
proche solidaire mais en même temps une
approche globale c'est à dire que on
accueille ensemble ceux qui ont vocation
à bénéficier de la protection
internationale c'est-à-dire à être des
réfugiés qu'on contrôle ensemble nos
frontières extérieures d'où la demande
que nous avons fait de mettre en place
des centres d'enregistrement et
d'identification qu'on appelle à
bruxelles des hotspots c'est à dire
qu'en italie en grèce camps des réfugiés
des immigrants se présente on puisse
savoir si effectivement ce seront des
réfugiés qui bénéficieront du droit
d'asile ou si ce sont des immigrés et
les îles et walker auquel cas d'une
façon évidemment humaine mais il faut
les raccompagner dans leur pays
d'origine dans le cadre d'un projet de
coopération avec les pays de provenance
et il faut que nous et il faut qu'une
mettions en place ensemble
cette politique de soutien aux pays
d'origine et de trois ans est d'abord
aux pays voisins avec la mairie
politique mais qu'on aurait pu appliquer
depuis longs mois de longs mois déjà et
peut-être contré pas dans cette si belle
souvient aujourd'hui à réviser la france
le propose depuis plus d'un an puis un
mois d'août 2014 ou parle pas de mon
août de cette année bernard cazeneuve
avait fait une tournée européenne pour
proposer cette approche commune
puisqu'il y a eu déjà un conseil
européen au mois de juin au cours duquel
le président de la république avait
demandé que soit mis en place ces
centres d'accueil ce contrôle commun de
la frontière et cette répartition
solidaire dans la queue dans l'accueil
dans les familles à une première
décision qu'ils ont appuyé sur 48
aujourd'hui sur 120 milles et je pense
que maintenant l'urgent c'est qu'il y
ait cette plaque fêlure à lens mais la
nippon annulé quand même bien l'inaction
de l'europe depuis de longs mois mais
commet alors il est encore une question
sur la hongrie on a entendu jean
christophe cambadélis le premier
secrétaire du ps demandé à la droite des
d'exclure sans partie du groupe ppe est
ce que vous êtes d'accord ce que vous
pensez que ce serait une décision plus
petits la wii cela ça relève des partis
je m'exprime pas au nom des partis mais
en tout cas c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui la
politique qui est défendu par des
gouvernements qui refusent de prendre
part à la solidarité européenne qui
veulent faire le tri entre les réfugiés
selon leur religion en disant on ne
prendra que ceux qui sont chrétiens ce
qui est d'ailleurs bien peu chrétien
comme morale et qui n'est pas du tout le
message que le pape a émis qui a été de
demander au contraire à tous les toutes
les paroisses d'europe d'accueillir des
réfugiés sans distinction d'origine
tous
je crois que tout cela c'est vrai que ça
met en cause les valeurs sur lesquelles
se sont toujours battus les grands
partis politiques pro européen qu'elle
soit démocrate chrétien ukip en quoi
cela comme alors sociaux démocrates mais
c'est pas à moi de me mêler d'un
caillebotis de chaque bout des nombreux
mails sans gloire sanctionné trop par le
parent par leur herbe en tous les cas
même désir mais mais il ya une autre
action au sein de la droite européenne
c'est clair puisqu'on a oui puisque la
réalité c'est qu'on a d'un côté un
certain nombre de chefs de gouvernement
européens qui sont confrontés à cette
crise des migrations et qui demande la
solidarité européenne et parfois au sein
de la même formation politique
européenne d'autres valeurs comme un
monsieur norman qui se refusent
totalement à prendre part à la solide
alors une question toute simple est ce
que certains pays ont le droit de dire
non on ne veut pas de réfugiés pour vous
est ce qu'un pays peut dire non je ne
peux pas parce que je n'ai je n'y arrive
pas je ne peux pas faire face jusqu'à
maintenant je veux dire non admises mais
des mères en france le 10 pour oui mais
attendez les pays qui constitue l'union
européenne sont tous engagés d'abord par
des conventions internationales sur le
droit d'un roman de pagnol non
deuxièmement nous sommes aussi engagés
par les principes et les règles de
l'union européenne à accueillir pas que
réfugiés qui sont menacés pour des
raisons d'ordre politique ou ou d'un trn
nature donc nous avons des obligations
légales va que ce que nous avons besoin
de bâtir maintenant c'est un système
d'asile commun parce que par exemple
qu'on a besoin d'une liste de pays sûrs
qu'il soit la même partout il y a aussi
parmi les huit cent mille migrants qui
se sont présentés en allemagne que
l'allemagne s'attend à devoir recevoir
parfois on parle même en allemagne d'un
million de personnes des gens qui
viennent par exemple des pays des
balkans qui aujourd'hui ne sont plus des
pays dont on a besoin d'avoir une
harmonisation des thèmes d'asile
d'accord en même temps qu'on a besoin
d'avoir une solidarité dans l'accueil
des réfugiés et en même temps qu'on a
besoin d'avoir aussi un contrôle commun
nos frontières je crois que vous allez
vers la mise en page de garde frontières
européens à accueillir donc les réfugiés
c'est un devoir qui s'impose à tous
comme l'avait dit françois hollande donc
certains résistent refuse même je
reviens à la question est ce que
l'europe peut imploser sur cette
question sachant que laurent fabius a
évoqué un risque de délitement et
d'extraits mise
sion oui si l'europe n'était pas capable
de se mettre d'accord sur une question
aussi essentielle pour sa crédibilité
mais aussi pour ses valeurs pour son son
humanité
évidemment que on voit bien qu'il y
aurait la tentation que chaque pays mène
une politique d'immigration ou d'accueil
des réglages vérove ça voudrait dire que
chacun rétablir des contrôles aux
frontières
ils peuvent être établies schengen ne
prévoit de fonctionner le problème nous
l'avons de france avec vitaly mais si
chacun remettait en cause cette espace
de libre circulation et cette solidarité
quand des états membres sont confrontés
à une urgence aujourd'hui donc ceux qui
sont en méditerranée eh bien il n'y
aurait plus d'unité européenne
c'est pourquoi la décision qui a été
prise aujourd'hui au conseil des
ministres de l'intérieur était une étape
absolument essentiel pour le maintien de
l'unité européenne et ça vous soulage
c'est pas simplement que ça me soulage
c'est que c'était indispensable et que
sa colère mais de bien préparer le
conseil européen demain où les chefs
d'état et de gouvernement vont devoir
notamment travaillé sur la politique que
nous proposons vis-à-vis des pays
d'origine ou de transit par exemple la
turquie qui accueille aujourd'hui près
de deux millions de réfugiés dans des
camps ou dans des situations précaires
la jordanie le liban mais aussi si on se
tourne du côté de l'afrique et du sel le
niger qui reçoit à la fois des migrants
qui viennent d'afrique de l'ouest et
d'afrique de l'est et qui tentent
d'aller vers la libye parce que cet état
c'est une poudre et qu'il est dans la
main de groupes gagnent réel de
trafiquants bien qui en suit met les
migrants peu attendons on a besoin
d'avoir aussi une politique extérieure
commune de l'union européenne
ils permettent de traiter à la source
ces désordres du monde
on a besoin de beaucoup de choses à du
côté européen on a besoin d un peu plus
on a parlé on va parler un peu du noeud
du problème notamment la situation en
syrie
harlem désir on voit que la russie a
décidé de passer à l'action elle a
déployé plus d'une vingtaine d'avions en
séries tout à fait récemment contre le
groupe etat islamique alors que nous
nous peinons avec la coalition
internationale est-ce qu'il est temps
effectivement de lui laisser un peu plus
le champ libre
est ce qu'il est temps pour l'europe de
lever ses sanctions contre moscou bon
d'abord la situation en syrie alors on
va pas développer toutes les infos sur
l'a6 en or or not
relations avec la syrie en syrie et avec
la russie mais la situation en syrie
elle demande une solution politique en
même temps qu évidemment de se donner
les moyens
militairement d'agir contre l'état
islamique puisque les informations nous
sont parvenus selon lesquelles depuis le
territoire syrien
ce groupe terroriste commandites ou
tentent de commandité des attentats en
europe y compris en france d'où la
décision du président de la république
de permettre qu'il y ait des vols de
reconnaissance qui déboucheront à gré
cela est nécessaire et s'il arrive sur
les phrases aris nalci la russie alors
la russie est une grande puissance qui
joue un rôle depuis toujours dans cette
région elle a une base en syrie à
tartous et elle soutient aujourd'hui le
régime et nous syriens se tient la
russie ont fait alliance avec la russie
nous nous disons depuis le début qu'il
n'y a pas de solution à la crise en
syrie par le maintien de bachar el assad
donc ce que nous souhaitons c'est en
discutant avec tous les partenaires qui
peuvent jouer un rôle pour trouver une
solution à la crise syrienne
évidemment la russie les etats-unis mais
aussi les pays de la région les pays
arabes l'iran avant de trouver une
solution qui corresponde à ce qu'on
appelle les négociations qui avaient eu
lieu à genève le communiqué de genève
c'est à dire qui permettent d'avoir une
transition politique qui associé à la
fois des éléments de l'opposition kirk
inc est une participation terroristes et
des éléments du régime sans bachar
el-assad qui ne sont pas encore nés dans
des crimes de la jouer en russie
oui mais si la russie veut participer à
cet accord pour cette transition
politique
c'est évidemment alors les choses qui
sait les humains n'ont ni s'il s'agit de
maintenir bachar el-assad
cela n'apportera pas de solution
puisqu'il est le responsable de cette
guerre civile
c'est lui qui a déclenché la répression
d'un mouvement populaire qui a ensuite
fait basculer toute une partie de la
syrie du côté des groupes islamistes
radicaux et qu' il n'y aura pas de fin à
cette guerre par le soutien à bachar
el-assad
bon ok on va évoquer maintenant une
autre crise qui est passée au second
plan
même s'il est moins aigu c'est celle de
la zone euro amd
alexis tsipras stade donc emporté
dimanche avec son parti syriza aux
élections législatives
et le revoilà donc comme premier
ministre attendue bien sûr sur les
réformes qu'il avait accepté l été
dernier c'est la deuxième question de
cette émission
peut-on faire confiance alexis tsipras
ce on les couteaux soir de sa victoire
et puis c'est perrine tarneaud qui vous
posera la question tout de suite après
ça a été une bataille difficile
aujourd'hui je me sens légitime parce
que le peuple grec nous a donné un
mandat clair pour continuer le combat à
l'intérieur et à l'extérieur du pays
les difficultés sont devant nous mais
nous avons une base solide nous savons
où aller
où mettre les pieds et quels seront nos
perspectives se sortir de la crise ne se
fera pas comme par magie
ce sera à force de travail en suivant un
plan avec ténacité et en luttant voilà
que vous êtes de ceux que la réélection
avec ses traits de d'alexis tsipras ce
pardon satisfait en tout cas il a reçu
la confiance puisque c'était la question
qui nous opposaient des citoyens en
grèce et je pense que sa réélection
valide aussi la stratégie qui avait été
celle du président de la république au
mois de juillet lorsqu'il ya eu ces
débats très difficile au sein du conseil
européen de considérer qu'à partir du
moment où alexis tsipras ce prenait des
engagements étaient prêts à mettre en
oeuvre un certain nombre de réformes sur
la modernisation de l'administration de
la fiscalité de l'économie en grèce
il fallait permettre qu'il y ait un
accord et le maintien de la grèce dans
la zone euro non seulement pour
l'intégrité de la zone euro mais aussi
pour l'intégrité de l'europe elle-même
et d'ailleurs on voit avec ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui sur les réfugiés
à quel point il aurait été totalement
dramatique de descartes et la grèce de
l'europe attend donc aujourd'hui ratifié
le fait de ne pas la maintenir dans la
zone euro donc je veux quand je la
félicite alexis tsipras il salue aussi
sa reconversion sa conversion au
réalisme à ce qu'il n'y a pas là un peu
de récupération politique
je crois qu alexis tsipras ce a fait la
preuve
puis qu'il a été élu comme premier
ministre au mois de janvier et puis
ensuite dans la façon il a conduit des
négociations qu'il pouvait à la fois
qu'il essayait en tout cas à la fois de
concilier l'aspiration un changement a
tourné la page de l'austérité et en même
temps à s'inscrire durablement dans la
construction européenne donc dans un
réalisme aussi par rapport à une
situation économique mais de tous côtés
oui celui qui a six mois et il ya six
mois il était effectivement la majorité
des européens le crémier il le rejeter
presque aujourd'hui c'était pas le cas
de la france c'est françois hollande qui
depuis le début c'est l'arrivée de la
gauche réformiste alors en tout cas
c'est une gauche réformiste qu'incarnent
aujourd'hui en grèce avec city press
c'est à dire à la fois une volonté de
justice sociale de réforme mais en même
temps la volonté de rester dans
l'ensemble européen et d'en respecter
les règles et c'était le double respect
auquel françois hollande avait appelé
peut-être à certains moments et est il
le seul mais finalement c'est la
position sur laquelle il a amené les
européens sur laquelle la france et
l'allemagne se sont retrouvés pour qu'il
y ait un accord avec la grèce au mois de
juillet c'est à dire le respect du choix
du peuple grec d'un changement et en
même temps le respect la moitié règles
européennes quasiment la moitié des
grecs ne se sont pas déplacés pour voter
dimanche soir écoutez il ya une élection
il l'a emporté très largement ceux qui
avaient fait dissidence ne sont pas
représentés au parlement parce qu'ils
n'ont pas atteint le seuil des 3% donc
ça montre que c'est la disette - qui nie
la réalité comme l'a dit hier manuel
valls a fait en allusion peut-être à
jean luc mélenchon arnaud montebourg qui
en france ont accueilli récemment
varoufakis l'ancienne star ce que alexis
tsipras ça aussi obtenu dans cette
discussion avec le soutien du président
de la république qu'il y ait le
sauvetage des banques qu'il y ait 83
milliards d' aide pour la grèce qu'il y
ait la possibilité qu'il y ait un plan
d'investissement et que donc le produit
des privatisations puisse être
réinjectés dans l'économie en grèce
qu'il y ait sociale afin de la question
michel mais pour ces mener à bien ses
réformes c'est un partenaire est
évidemment qu'on doit travailler sur la
base de la confiance et que nous
travaillons en confiance avec alexis
tsipras cette branche village soutien de
des citoyens d'un soutien du peuple grec
je crois qu'il faut aider ce
gouvernement qui a engagé des réformes
qui ne l'avait pas été jusqu'à présent
par aucun des gouvernements précédents
en grèce qui était prisonnier d'une
forme de clientélisme
il faut donc l'aider à mettre en oeuvre
cette modernisation de l'économie et de
la société alors c'est étrange parce que
effectivement donc vous vous répondez
oui je fais confiance il faut faire
confiance alexis tsipras s'agira garde
la gauche réformiste vous l'avez dit or
la gauche de la gauche de la gauche
radicale en france lui maintient son
soutien parce que justement pour elle
pour le parti de gauche pour le front de
gauche pour rien que les héros entre le
style de la gauche radicale qui évoquait
un instant perry des l'incarnent contre
l'austérité la vraie gauche entre
guillemets oui mais ça chacun peut avoir
la lecture mais il s'agit pas de
récupérer moi je m'exprime par rapport à
un gouvernement qui vient de remporter
une élection et qui a fait un choix très
courageux c'est le maintien de la grèce
dans la zone euro et d'accepter de
mettre en oeuvre un certain nombre de
réformes j'ai évoqué celle de la
fiscalité par exemple qui avait des gens
en grèce qui paient pas d'impôts puisque
les amateurs parce que il avait je ne
sais quelle catégorie d'exemption une
réforme de l'administration une réforme
de l'économie
et tout cela c'est une modernisation de
la grèce mais qui se fait en même temps
avec des des objectifs sociaux
après c'est alexis tsipras ce de dire
dans quelle famille politique européenne
il veut s'inscrire mais pour nous c'est
un partenaire et les liens entre la
france et la grèce sont ceux qui nous
ont amené à soutenir la grèce quand elle
a fait ce choix de rester dans la zone
euro même si d'autres eux avaient pour
projet de la sortir de la zone euro et
heureusement que la france a été là et
nous sommes heureux que aujourd'hui on
dit s'attend à perdre il faut commencer
tout de suite les réformes c'est ce que
vous lui dites ce sommet surtout il les
a déjà commencé parce que vous savez que
déjà au mois de juillet au mois d'août
il ya eu plusieurs train de réformes qui
ont adopté des réformes très difficile
certaines qui concerne le système de
retraite par exemple l'organisation de
l'administration publique et vous êtes
immigrés quand même maintenant je crois
pas je crois que franchement il ya très
peu de pays qui ont été amenés à faire
en aussi peu de temps des réformes
justement qu'elle n'avait pas été fait
depuis quinze ou vingt ans justement
ailleurs on sait que le pays et serait
sur le plan économique
beaucoup d'économistes dit ça va être
pire demain avec la purge qu'on lui
impose ça c'est la vraie question c'est
que il ne suffit pas que la grèce met en
corner un assainissement et qu'on impose
à la grèce
il ya des mesures de ré de dison de
modernisation de la dépense publique il
ya des mesures de hausse de la fiscalité
par exemple de la rivière des grecs qui
sont déjà là où donc sont prêts à
supporter de nouvelles hausses d'impôts
fin donc là c'est sa recette c'est pour
cette raison que dans l'accord qui était
passé au mois de juillet il ya un volet
soutien aux investissements qu'avec le
président de la commission européenne
jean claude juncker nous avons défendu
pour la grèce c'est à dire 35 milliards
d'investissements qui doivent être
injectés dans l'économie grecque
au cours des prochaines années parce que
vous avez raison de dire que s'il n'y a
que les réformes et l'assainissement
budgétaire
le risque c'est que l'économie ne
redémarre pas mais je crois que la grèce
a des atouts elle et l'a montré le
prononce secteurs comme le tourisme et
il y en a beaucoup d'autres il ya des
jeunes qui suivent des études de haut
niveau il ya des universités à
l'étranger cela depuis longtemps
oui mais justement donc ça veut dire
alors si l'économie redémarre ils
peuvent contribuer à la relance
et pour finir sur la grèce justement est
ce que le prochain dossier sur la table
ce n'est pas l'art les négociations pour
restructurer la dette grecque
oui c'est d'ailleurs une discussion qui
commencent d'ores et déjà et qui
effectivement est aussi une étape très
importante dans la mise en oeuvre de ce
plan de redressement de la grèce parce
que à cause de la situation depuis la
crise de 2009 alors que la grèce a
accumulé un endettement qui aujourd'hui
est trop important et donc parmi les
éléments de l'accord que alexis tsipras
a obtenu avec le soutien de la france il
ya un rééchelonnement de cette dette
pour que ça non ça ne viennent pas
griller la reprise économique on avait
une autre question
oui le scandale volkswagen 11 millions
de voitures dans le monde équipés d'un
logiciel de trucage aux tests anti
pollution alors l'europe harlem désir
qui se veut si ils reprochable en
matière de lutte contre la pollution
quel exemple le terrible un monde
d'hommes justement avant la cap 21
bon c'est aux états unis que tafer à une
firme européenne est absolument mais je
veux dire par là que ce sont les
véhicules volkswagen aux états unis qui
donc se sont avérées raison les mêmes
moteurs qui tournent en europe mais
c'est ce qu'il faut bien inquiet
ce que les voitures de la même marque en
europe
eux aussi ont finalement été l'objet
d'un trucage pour ne pas répondre aux
tests de pollution donc il y à une
demande et une demande qui était formée
par la chancelière d'allemagne angela
merkel qui a demandé la transparence la
plus totale
vamos vague n je crois que c'est
exactement l'exigence qu'il faut avoir
aujourd'hui et il faut donc qu'à
l'échelle européenne il puisse y avoir
maintenant une enquête qui permette non
vérifiées menée par les instances qui
sont en charge de la lutte contre la
pollution automobile en europe mais
chaque état membre a aussi des agences
par exemple nous a lu tac et saisir
aujourd'hui maire pour vérifier que les
véhicules qui sont commercialisés en
europe respectent les normes alors que
les six ont rassuré tout ça il faut
faire face dit on au poids des lobbys
dans l'industrie automobile et écouter
ce que dit la sénatrice écologiste de
paris leila aichi à ce sujet les experts
ne sont pas totalement indépendant et ça
c'est vraiment important que ce soit ce
soit le cas c'est une commission d'
enquête européenne qu'on devrait mettre
en place française également par
ailleurs d'après le gouvernement veut se
saisir de cette de cette question parce
que c'est une question de santé publique
voilà les la chique à travailler ici au
sénat justement sur la pollution de
l'air c'est vrai à qui on peut faire
confiance
le poids du lobby automobile tellement
fort je crois que les instances
européennes de contrôle en matière de
pollution de l'air sont des instances
indépendantes et il faut qu'elle soit
saisie et il faut à la fois pour des
raisons de santé publique mais aussi de
confiance des acheteurs des usagers
vis-à-vis des grandes marques
automobiles que la vérité soit connue et
qu' on puisse avoir la garantie que
toutes les automobiles quels qu'en
soient les marques et soit européenne
non qui sont vendus en europe respectent
les normes antipollution europe et
conjurer les constructeurs français mais
vous avez parlé des grandes valeurs qui
fédèrent l'europe aujourd'hui il ya là
elles sont attaqués directement
effectivement perrine a raconté l'image
que l'on veut donner à l'europe sert de
l'angle de la lutte pour l'environnement
c'est là vous le déplorez
c'est une marque privée c'est pas une
institution publique européenne qui a
répondu la fraude a eu lieu aux états
unis ou en europe
donc ce que nous voulons savoir si ce
qui ne calme et donc ne commençons pas
pas remettre en cause l'europe quand il
sait jamais l'image est l'image de
volkswagen est durement atteinte
évidemment mais l'image d'un continent
peut-être aussi parce que wigan
c'est aussi une incarnation de la
pénibilité connaît très bien le jir
mouais moi je l'aiderai nature est
rappelé que souvent en europe les
industriels se sont plaints parce que
les normes de protection contre la
pollution des eaux des sols de l'air
sont extrêmement élevés ce sont les plus
élevés au monde
il ya une directive par exemple sur les
produits chimiques la directive reach
qui met en oeuvre des contrôles
extrêmement précis sur tous les procédés
industriels à la fois pour protéger les
travailleurs de de ces entreprises mais
aussi pour faire en sorte qu'il n'y ait
pas dans les matériaux qui sont ensuite
au contact des enfants par exemple ou
tout simplement du grand public des
éléments cancérigènes
il y à des normes extrêmement précises
sur les industries automobile et sur les
à la fois l'essence sans plomb le
contrôle des particules qui sont émises
le nombre de grammes de co2 et c'est
donc tout ces limbes
c'est l'europe qui des amis en oeuvre en
premier et qui exerce un contrôle sur la
façon dont les industriels
si enfin les nommés sont pas vraiment il
ne mettons pas en cause leur argent qui
viennent non mais ne mettons pas en
cause l'europe pour l'instant elle ne
l'est pas mais assurons nous que
l'europe compte tenu de la formation qui
concerne une grande marque automobile
européenne mais internationale qui vend
aussi face à elle véhicule sur le marché
intérieur européen
vérifions effectivement qu' il n'y a pas
eu la même frôlé à queue dans notre
continent un petit mot de l'angleterre
pour terminer cette partie harlem désir
puisque c'est quand même l'autre danger
qui guette l'union européenne la sortie
potentielle de la deuxième puissance
économique de l'europe
l'angleterre est ce que vous faites plus
confiance à david cameron que nouvel
homme fort de la gauche du mr bean
parce que c'est vrai que le voilà le
sujet pour l'europe c'est le référendum
que david cameron a annoncé sur le
maintien ou non de la grande bretagne
d'un héroïque des mines ou en 2016
d'après le souhait du gouvernement
britannique même si je crois qu'il peut
aussi reporté ce référendum
un peu plus tard s'ils le souhaitent
nous nous souhaitons que la grande
bretagne reste dans l'union européenne
nous pensons que c'est un moment où
l'europe a besoin je les ai dit tout à
l'heure de se rassembler parce qu'elle
fait face à des grands défis qu aucun
pays ne peut affronter seul parmi la
crise des réfugiés oui mais vous avez lu
là on parlait de pollution industrielle
parce qu'il va vouloir négocier david
cameron pourrait d'accord mais il y a
des éléments peut-être la grande
bretagne va formuler plus précisément
qui concerne le fonctionnement de
l'union européenne souvent en grande
bretagne à des critiques contre la
bureaucratie bon bah ça si on peut
améliorer la simplicité la simplicité du
fonctionnement des institutions
européennes
il n'y a pas de difficultés mais nous
nous ne voulons pas remettre en cause
les principes de l'union européenne par
exemple il ya des gens en grande
bretagne qui veulent remettre en cause
la liberté de circulation des citoyens
européens
on ne parle pas de réfugiés un ou deux
résidants qui viendrait d'un autre pays
mais le fait que des citoyens polonais
par exemple puisse aller s'installer
dans un autre pays de l'union européenne
ça nous ne pouvons pas l'accepter
il ya des gens qui veulent remettre en
cause la possibilité qu à la zone euro
de continuer à s'intégrer ça nous nous
reconnaissons que tout le monde ne
participe pas à la zone euro c'est le
choix de la grande bretagne où d'autres
pays de ne pas être membre de la monnaie
commune mais on ne doit pas empêcher les
pays qui veulent aller de l'avant de
continuer à le faire donc nous
souhaitons que la grande bretagne reste
dans l'europe qu'elle en restant membre
vous êtes a décrit cet après midi
partenaires dans vos petites femelles
mais ne doit pas évidemment essayer de
bloquer l'intégration de ceux qui
souhaitent aller plus loin dans la
construction d'une union politique de
l'europe merci perrine tarneaud alors
troisième partie de l'émission de
preuves par 3 ans maintenant et cette
question harlem désir vous tremblez déjà
regardé ça emmanuel macron at il encore
sa place au gouvernement
la réponse est extrêmement ça wily a
toute sa place et il n'y a pas beaucoup
on va vous interpeller un peu comme on
aura pour elle se pose est bien sûr il
est posé au sein du parti socialiste
peut-être moins au gouvernement nommé
par m
l'âge aux rites et certains de vos
collègues sont un peu plus vif quand il
évoque la dernière sortie des mêmes à
l'écran sur le statut des fonctionnaires
écouté par exemple la ministre de la
fonction publique
marylise lebranchu et puis vous
répondrai plus longuement dans une
trente secondes à samir tounsi est pas
un problème macro moi je veux pas taper
sur un collègue du gouvernement je dis
simplement que la ministre n'ait jamais
libre de s'exprimer sans avoir construit
une pensée collective avec l'ensemble de
de ses collègues sur un point parce que
le risque c'est justement celui là c'est
à dire qu'à partir d'une question posée
sur l'encadrement et bien on met
permettez moi l'expression un peu le feu
partout et en particulier dans les
syndicats de la fonction publique
alors là il a mis le feu un peu partout
même à la con bon soir le voici un bon
choix harlem désir pour ce faire vous
avez un peu de suspense à laquelle tout
à l'heure j'en suis navré vous avez
cependant un jeune ministre qui vient
pas du sérail politique est-ce qu'il
doit apprendre les codes et ce qui doit
revenir au précédent chevènement
ministre ça ferme sa gueule ou ça
démissionne
je crois surtout que là il ya eu sur la
base d'une phrase qui était prononcé non
pas dans une interview mais je crois
dans une sorte de colloque auquel
participaient emmanuel macron avec
quelques amis et qui a ensuite a été
gonflé comme s'il s'agissait d'une
annonce 3 qu'emmanuel macro ont expliqué
lui même il n'y a pas de mise en cause
du statut des fonctionnaires
on a besoin de fonctionnaires dans notre
pays d'ailleurs les français qui peut
être peuvent trouver que il ya trop de
fonctionnaires en général ils sont
général demandeurs qui est des
enseignants dans leur école est plutôt
plus ce qui est des infirmières dans les
hôpitaux qui est des gendarmes pour la
sécurité qui est des policiers qui est
des militaires donc on a besoin de
défendre des fonctionnaires qui ont le
statut de la fonction publique ça veut
pas dire qu'il ya un débat interdit sur
les réformes de l'état où les réformes
qui pourraient intervenir dans tel ou
tel domaine mais il n'y a pas
aujourd'hui de mise en cause du statut
des fonctionnaires estion on a entendu
votre collègue maryse lebranchu dire
qu'un ministre n'est pas libre de sa
parole et à lorient demain mais
d'informer
non je crois pas que se former comme ça
elle n'a pas du tout mis en cause en
tout cas d'appartenance des manuels
maintenant au gouvernement sur vos de
riberolles pouviez laissé entendre
non mais simplement nous devons nous
exprimer sur ce sur quoi nous agissons
et c'est d'ailleurs ce qu'a fait le
premier ministre est aux manettes mais
le vent les devoirs les parlementaires
socialistes il l'a fait pour pour pour
toute la majorité et je crois que tout
le monde en est d'accord nous agissons
sur beaucoup de domaines à la fois c'est
d'ailleurs un des défis auxquels nous
sommes confrontés nous sommes obligés à
la fois de régler les problèmes qui ne
l'avait pas été auparavant celui par
exemple des déficits et de l'endettement
de la france au même temps de travailler
sur la compétitivité de notre économie
parce qu'elle avait pris du retard et
que c'est la clé pour la croissance et
pour l'emploi de travailler sur
l'égalité renforcer les moyens de
l'école et nous allons aussi mettre en
oeuvre une grande loi sur la lutte
contre les discriminations sur l'égalité
en matière urbaine
nous devons agir pour relancer l'europe
nous devons agir sur la scène
internationale comme nous l'avons fait
pour moi il a à la veille de la
recherche il lance un ballon d'essai sur
les 35 heures ce matin ses politiques
devant le groupe du parti socialiste à
l'assemblée nationale
il a irrité certains députés
yann galut un des députés qu'il est
convenu d'appeler frondeurs a dit que ce
genre de propos sur les 35 heures sur
les fonctionnaires bref sur ce qui fait
quand même l'adn de l'électorat de
gauche étaient irresponsables dans la
période c'est à dire à quelques mois des
élections régionales vous partager le
constat que quand on est un ministre
d'un gouvernement de gauche on ne peut
pas se permettre comme ça des ballons
d'essai qui peuvent et bien braquer une
partie de notre électorat
je crois très franchement ce qui est
intéressé les français dans l'action ça
les intérêts du gouvernement qui ont en
particulier dans le domaine de
l'économie qui est celui dont s'occupe
emmanuel macron ces derniers mois c'est
la loi dont il a été le rapporteur sur
la croissance et l'activité
c'est par exemple le fait qu'il y ait un
certain de nouveaux secteurs d'activités
qui sont en train de se développer
les autocars je crois qu'il est allé lui
même
sur le terrain en ardèche il y a
quelques jours pour montrer comment cela
crée de l'emploi et du design chez le
plafonnement là c'est par exemple le
plafonnement des indemnités de
licenciement aux prud'hommes qui avaient
envie ce fondement
ce sont des réservoirs un sujet a quand
même vous avec moi ne sont pas dans
l'adn de rémy côté ils sont des sujets
qui ont fait l'objet vous parlez du
travail du dimanche d'un encadrement
très rigoureux avec des compensations
avec des négociations avec les syndicats
avec pour ce qui est des zones
touristiques des délits mais des
délimitations très précises tout ça a
été discuté au parlement et tout ça je
crois intéresse les français
oui faire avancer l'économie moderniser
le fonctionnement de l'économie
française créer de l'activité et de
l'emploi et c'est d'ailleurs sur ces
sujets que s'expriment emmanuel macron
donc moi je ne participerai pas à je ne
sais quel est le commentaire de
commentaires vous ne citez un député est
ce que vous avez saisi ne sais pas je
pense que lui même sans doute est plus
intéressé par les réformes qui sont
mises en oeuvre par le gouvernement et
par emmanuel macron que par des
questions à une question personnelle
parce que les propos tenus en dehors
d'une interview et d'un cadre d'une
question personnelle puisque les
ministres ne peuvent pas totalement
s'exprimer d'une dizaine marylise
lebranchu 1 en dehors de leurs cadres
est ce que vous êtes personnellement
séduit par la gauche moderne que veut
incarner aujourd'hui emmanuel macron oui
ou non un même désir meiway numéro non
mais la politique que défend emmanuel
macron comme ministre c'est celle du
gouverneur rivard combien plus mien il
yad'autres dès janvier nouveau oui oui
mais alors avec un soutien de l'ensemble
du gouvernement au hasard c'est le jura
qui lui est donnée à la fois par le
président la république et par le
premier ministre quand par exemple il
fait cette loi sur la croissance et
l'activité et dans l'eure chacun des
ministres à sa personnalité vous voulez
parce que vous envoyez moi ya comme une
politique du gouvernement vous flatter
tout à l'heure avec celle ci passe vous
voyez comme un héros de la gauche
moderniste voulait pas dire les mêmes
mots pourrait m'amener jacques roset dit
que emmanuel macron était un très bon
ministre
qui alors évidemment a toute sa place au
sein du gouvernement cela n'est mis en
cause par personne même parce qu'ils ont
pu émettre des critiques et qui apporte
beaucoup par son activité par par son
dynamisme à l'action du gouvernement
mais il n'y a qu'une politique du
gouvernement et on va laisser d'adressé
récent du relais français
on va tenter de poser la question
autrement d'antan beaucoup aujourd'hui
dans la bouche du président de la
république la dispersion
c'est la disparition dans la bouche du
premier ministre au congrès des radicaux
ce dimanche à montpellier dans la bouche
du preuve de votre successeur à la tête
du parti socialiste des appels à l'unité
à l'union c'est pas tellement nouveau
dans l'histoire de la gauche mais on
peut faire l'union de la gauche a encore
une fois deux mois et demi des
régionales avec un ministre qui a un
profil social libéral aussi affirmé au
gouvernement mais écoutez très
franchement quand on quand on voit ce
qui s'est passé à noisy-le-grand ce
week-end où il y avait une élection
municipale partielle
vous vous lagon et la colère de la
volonté majoritaire mais il y avait deux
listes de gauche au second tour une
liste de rassemblement des socialistes
et d'écologistes et une liste du front
de gauche et le résultat a été que cette
dispersion des voix de gauche a permis à
la droite de l'emporter d'une trentaine
de voix alors encore une fois que la
majorité des citoyens ont porté leur que
leurs suffrages sur des listes de gauche
est-ce que la leçon à tirer ce n'est pas
que il est absolument indispensable et
urgent faso ou aux immenses ce défis
auxquels le pays est confronté que
l'ensemble de la gauche avec des
coopérations front national et face à
l'extrême droite et face à une droite
dont une partie dérive vers le populisme
réactionnaire et courent derrière
l'extrême droite
il est urgent que l'ensemble à l'heure
et gauche se rassemble des militants du
front de gauche ce qui n'est pas le cas
il vous répondrait mais enfin si des
situations politiques tels qu à
noisy-le-grand se produisent ou si une
partie l'électorat populaire est attiré
par le front national c'est un c'est en
raison de la politique que vous menez le
pack de responsabilité l'allègement des
charges sur les entreprises les
collectivités locales mise au régime sec
et on y revient un ministre de
l'économie qui présente un profil social
libéral qui qui froisse beaucoup de gens
à la gauche du ps et à la gauche de la
gauche
vous connaissez cet argument est
évidemment oui mais la politique qui est
menée par le gouvernement c'est à la
fois une politique de redressement de la
situation économique du pays et ça passe
c'est vrai par le fait d' alléger la
fiscalité sur les ménages sur les
entreprises de guetta de la décharge du
mayet cache pot 2 b thriller de baisser
les déficits de ne pas laisser aux
générations futures des monceaux de
milliards d'endettement et en même temps
c'est une politique qui donne la
priorité à l'éducation c'est une
politique de soutien aux quartiers
qu'ils sont
plus en difficulté c'est une politique
de justice sociale c'est une politique
qui fait reculer les inégalités il ya
des statistiques qui viennent d'être
publiés et qui montrent que les
inégalités recul en france depuis que la
gauche est revenu aux responsabilités et
donc c'est une politique de gauche il ya
des différences au sein de la gauche de
yann lynch de gauche mais bien sûr c'est
une politique de gauche mais il ya
toujours eu des différences au sein de
la gauche
souvenons nous mêmes de l'époque du
programme commun en 1972 de ce qu'on
croit qu'il n'est pas sur une analyse
avions à l'époque mais mais sur le
périmètre des nationales sont là sa
porte sur les enveloppes très bien un
tir pour la vente de chars à empêcher la
gauche de s'unir et de se rassembler et
salubre et 3 est ce qu avait pas de
différence même sur la vision du monde
sur la largeur la norme gri gri allait
pourtant et pourtant l'ensemble des
familles de la gauche contre eux mais
qu'il fallait tenir si on voulait que la
gauche agissent et gouverne à la fois au
plan national et dans l'école invités le
jour parvenir pour forcer cette union
jean christophe cambadélis a trouvé la
martingale
voilà un référendum du peuple de gauche
sur l'unité sur le modèle du référendum
pour la sauvegarde de la poste il ya
quelques années quand au temps béni où
vous étiez dans l'opposition vous aviez
pas autant de deux problèmes de
paradoxes agirait vous allez voter à ces
référendums vous allez partir d'octobre
j'ai participerait je pense comme
beaucoup d'hommes et de femmes de gauche
parce que c'est un mal en vous êtes un
de mobilisation pour les granges de
beaucoup de responsables de gauche
écologiste cécile duflot emmanuelle
cosse
sans parler de pierre laurent et
jean-luc mélenchon ont envoyé nos fins
de non recevoir
assez assez sec jean luc mélenchon parle
d'un nouveau garrot pour éviter
l'hémorragie des électeurs de gauche
là on a encore un exemple très concret
des fins d'un appel à l'unité qui est
purement incantatoire avec sur le
terrain un gouffre qui se creuse non je
pense je pense que ça sera un signal que
je pense tous les dirigeants politiques
seront obligés de le prendre en compte
je pense que ça va provoquer un débat et
qu'on ne peut pas quand il ya notamment
deux grandes régions la région nord pas
de calais et celle la région paca qui
risque de basculer à l'extrême droite
balayée d'un revers de main cette
question de savoir comment est ce qu'on
fait pour que des formations politiques
de gauche qui sont certes diverses mais
qui ont gouverné ensemble les régions
qui ont un bilan commun et qui est un
bon bilan qui ont fait avancer le
développement économique
l'éducation la formation professionnelle
pendant six ans à l'exécutif de ces
régions comment est ce qu'on fait pour
qu'elle ne se présente pas une façon
incohérente et dispersées au suffrage
des électeurs et pour que ces régions
continue à être dirigé sur un programme
progressiste un programme de justice
sociale et de développement économiques
donc c'est ça qui est en jeu on peut pas
simplement dire c'est une question
secondaire et chacun ayant des
différence souhaite présenter sa propre
liste
si cela comporte le risque que ces
régions passe à l'extrême droite on va
pas encore tellement clair dans le 14 au
soir vous allez avoir sans doute 80% 98%
de faveur de deux oui en faveur de
l'unité réponse à la question posée vous
n'aurez que là on verra mais nos régions
oui mais alors après on sera un mois et
demi des élections à ce moment là que
vont faire les appareils enfin
visiblement les autres appareils
politiques vont se moquer éperdument de
ce résultat d'un référendum qui vont
considérer comme un petit arrangement
entre militants social mais je crois que
précisément le problème ce ne sont pas
des appareils comme vous le dites vous
même la question qui intéresse les
français c'est de savoir quelles sont
les politiques publiques qui vont être
menées dans les régions pendant les six
prochaines années
en france aussi quelle politique on
souhaite pour l'éducation pour l'emploi
pour le développement économique pour
l'europe c'est cela qui doit le
déterminer évidemment qu'il ya des
différences entre les différentes
formations politiques je préfère parler
de formation politique que d'appareils
mais ces différences elles ne nous ont
jamais empêchés d'agir ensemble entend
tout cas nous avions l'intérêt général
supérieur du pays
présent à l'esprit aller aujourd'hui est
supérieur à voir si les rênes à ce que
vous dites à vos partenaires on va se
quitter avec des images du pape parce
que vous l'aimez beaucoup il vous a
beaucoup impressionné lorsque vous
l'avez rencontré goisbeault il quitte
cuba pour aller aux états unis vous avez
vu ces images de liesse évidemment à
cuba vous l'avez vu avec fidel castro
qui vous inspirent toujours le même
sentiment
oui d'abord c'est vrai que c'est un pape
qui portent des messages qui sont très
forts je pense notamment à l'encyclique
la publier sur l'environnent
l'environnement sur le changement
climatique en s'inspirant de saint
françois d'assise et aujourd'hui il
et là pour contribuer à ouvrir cuba et
il a joué un rôle dans le rétablissement
des relations diplomatiques on trouvera
les états unis comme la france
d'ailleurs
et ce voyage est très important bien
entendu merci à vous merci samir merci à
tous bonsoir arias très vite
hu